à ce que je sache il pas encore de
projet concret d'exploitation la rue
daru sur cette question le cac de
clarifier ses positions
les candidats de la cac
aux îles-de-la-madeleine et contre
l'exploitation du pétrole provenant du
gisement old harry situé entre les îles
et terre-neuve ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que son propre parti à une
position bien différente
la caq estime que le projet old harry
est intéressant et mérite rossi à table
enfin depuis 2012 françois legault
affiche la même constance il est ouvert
à l'exploration et l'exploitation de
gisements comme old harry
et c'est la même chose pour l'île
d'anticosti en autant que ça soit fait
en respectant l'environnement
à l'époque de jean charest les libéraux
s'intéresser aux gisements du golfe
saint-laurent avec philippe couillard le
parti a clairement fermé la porte au
pétrole d'anticosti
le gouvernement libéral a même versé des
millions de dollars aux pétrolières pour
qu'elles quittent l'île
on skie du projet aux tarifs et les
couillard s'est toujours montré très
réticent en raison des risques pour
l'environnement
les madelinots sont en équipe avec
raison parce que s'il y avait
malheureusement un jour exploitation
pétrolière puis un incident ils sont
directement sur la ligne de feu au pq on
a assisté un virage à 180 degrés sous
pauline marois le pétrole québécois
était au coeur de la politique
énergétique du parti nous allons de
l'avant afin de confirmer le potentiel
pétrolier de l'île d'anticosti
mais depuis l'arrivée de jean françois
lisée le pq est carrément opposés du
côté de québec solidaire et la position
est la même depuis 2012 mettre fin aux
recherches et à l'exploitation des
énergies fossiles